[Music]
it's a great pleasure to come to the
white head and that's MIT and to to take
part in this wonderful symposium it's a
great challenge to speak here too for
several reasons for example Doug Melton
asked for a complete transcript of my
talk that's the first time in history
secondly Bruce Springsteen I think
throat a song about giving a talk here
called it blinded by the lights another
thing that makes it difficult to speak
here is is that as I was putting in my
trying to put in my slides the other
speakers were we're having to pass
judgment on the number and quality of
the slides and it's a pretty tough group
finally there's we heard about the
Whitehead curse last time about having
newspaper reporters call in the middle
of the night that wasn't a problem
now today's session this morning session
in the meeting has to do with cell-cell
interactions and and the different
diverse biological roles that they play
and that's one of the things I really
like about this symposium why I'm
learning a lot and will learn a lot
because it really represents a lot of
different organisms and everybody here
has their own favorite organism or two
and but let me also say even though we
have favourites we're not chauvinistic
about the organism larry's of persky's
very fond of Joseph Allah I love a yeast
and corn smut bob horvitz likes
nematodes and people like Doug Melton
and Marc Kirschner are known for running
around kissing beautiful women and
hoping they'll turn into frogs at any
rate I'm going to discuss the roles of
cell signaling in two organisms
the familiar baker's yeast budding yeast
and also a less familiar organism one of
the basidiomycetes that Mike Brown
mentioned yesterday in this case used to
lago made us and the first half will be
on budding yeast the second half will be
on ustah lago made us and let me just
say that in examining the life cycles of
these organisms what we're going to see
is the roles of different types of
molecular machinery and programming
their life cycle and to the to molecular
machine machinery that i'm going to talk
about the first one is regulatory
proteins and the second machinery that
we'll talk about our cell signaling
systems so in both cases we'll see the
role and the interplay of gene
regulators and cell-cell interactions
and programming different parts of life
cycle also I want to describe genetic
control and to some extent environmental
control of cell morphogenesis in these
two organisms and so there will be a lot
of links between the two organisms that
I probably present too much information
but I hope that the overview of these
two organisms will come
Crosse so the first organism you're
familiar with is budding yeast and
they're three cell types in this
organism a cells mate with alpha cells
alpha cells mate with a cells and the a
alpha diploid x' the product of the
mating and it does not mate with either
cell type but it undergoes meiosis
so these play roles in the lifecycle of
the organism and these specializations
of these organisms come about by natural
alleles Matt a which programs the a cell
type and met alpha which programs the
alpha cell type the the mating type plus
I alleles code for three regulatory
activities alpha one is a
transcriptional activator it's a
positive regulator it turns on
transcription of alpha specific genes
alpha 2 is a negative as a repressor
which turns off a specific genes and a 1
alpha 2 is another repressor which turns
off another set of genes two haploid
specific genes just to demonstrate alpha
2 and an alpha cell the alpha 2 protein
is a repressor and it this is a low
resolution view and it binds to the
upstream region of all these genes which
are genes that are important for a cells
to mate receptors etc mating factors so
this is a low resolution view of alpha 2
here's a high resolution view done by
Cynthia wahlburger and Carl Pei blows
lab in collaboration with sandy Johnson
alpha 2 is a homeo domain protein which
binds to DNA in essentially exactly the
same manner as in grail protein binds to
DNA now a particular regulator that I
want to call your attention to because
they're something like it will show up
in the second half of the talk is a 1
alpha 2 which is the molecular signature
of this cell type the a alpha cell type
a 1 alpha 2 is a heterodimeric repressor
work from carolyn gute and sandy
johnson's lab shows that this repressor
has two subunits a 1 and alpha 2 and it
binds to DNA more or less in this manner
and in so doing a 1 alpha to represses
many genes it's a repressor with many
target genes it turns off transcription
of h OG n-- it turns off transcription
of a whole herd of genes that are
involved in cell signaling that's
important for haploids
it turns off a retro transpose xi turns
off the genes involved in cell fusion
etc now that's the regulatory proteins
they turn on and turn off the
appropriate genes but cell
specialization the differentiation
process of yeast occurs in its full form
only at the appropriate time only when a
cell sees its mating partner so an alpha
cell turns on the final differentiation
of an a cell and the a cell turns on
final differentiation of an alpha cell
and they do that by secreting peptide
mating factors alpha factors thirteen
amino acids and a factor is twelve amino
acids with a modified cysteine to
farnesylated cysteine it's hard -
hydroxy methylated as well so they act
extra Sara Lee to turn on the final
differentiation now alpha factor causes
the target cells to do three main things
to arrest in g1 to undergo morphological
changes and to turn on transcription of
a whole bunch of genes so alpha factor
is a differentiation factor it's a
negative growth factor and it's turning
on the the final differentiation of the
mating partner and I want to comment on
quickly on the mechanism of
transcriptional induction and then g1
arrest
so alpha factor causes arrest here in
the cell cycle in g1 and this
demonstrates how how we ask say that in
the lab this is a patch of alpha cells
and the alpha cells are inhibiting
growth of the lawn the lawn is a bunch
of a cells and you see that there's a
zone of inhibition here as the alpha
cells inhibit the cells in the lawn
now this shows you alpha factor has a
potent effect on cherry tomatoes this is
without alpha factor this is without the
factor now the machinery for response to
mating factors is shown here each cell
has a specific receptor alpha cells have
a receptor that allows it to respond to
the a factor a cells have a receptor
which allows it to respond to alpha
factor we know the genes that encode
these receptors and they're regulated in
a cell type specific manner only alpha
cells have this gene expressed only a
cells have this gene expressed and all
the intracellular machinery is the same
in both a cells and alpha cells and that
can be shown by doing receptor swap
experiments so that's what's on the cell
surface now let's look inside the cell
and see what the machinery is so here on
the left is an unstimulated cell we have
the the receptor is the seven membranes
spanning type and it has a it's
associate a sidekick this hetero
trimeric g-protein which exists in the
gdp-bound form and in the unstimulated
state the fuse one gene discovered and
Jerry thinks lab and involved in cell
fusion is off and the g1 cyclin-cdk SLIB
ER ating a beta gamma subunit which then
triggers the pathway and a lot of these
steps have not been worked out
biochemically but there's progress being
made literally every day and I'm giving
you a sort of the best guess of the
pathway right now beta gamma somehow
stimulates sterile us let's go to the
end of the pathway and show that at the
end of the pathway the fuse one gene
which used to be off is now its
transcription is now stimulated and the
far gene whose protein inhibits seoeon 1
and CN 2 is turned on and that causes
and it caused a cell cycle arrest and
this these genes are transcribed because
sterile 12 the transcription factor has
become active and it's become active
because upstream are some protein kinase
is seized three again discovered in the
Finke lab by healing on Elaine de Leon
and these proteins map kinase relatives
somehow activates Darryl 12 presumably
by phosphorylation sterile 7 is almost
certainly the map kinase kinase and
sterile 11 one can argue as a regulator
of sterile 7s another protein tiny so
beta gamma triggers a whole series of
protein kinases to then activate a
transcription factor which then turns on
transcription of a whole bunch of genes
important for the mating process so
that's why the final differentiation
occurs only at the right time because
the mating factors trigger that
differentiation now to progress from G 1
to s 1 requires protein kinase p34 with
it's appropriate cyclones likewise to
proceed from G 2 to M 1 requires an
active protein kinase and in budding
yeast there are g1 cyclin-cdk s-- is far
which is identified by Fred Chiang and
now we know quite a bit about how far
acts and I don't have time to show you
the data but this is the essence of what
we now know about the regulation and
activation of far once again there's a
map kinase kinase Terrell 7 which
phosphorylates these map kinases this
has been shown now from therefore they
already Gustav Omer and Kim Naismith
somehow sterile 12 is activated that
turns on far now the far protein by
itself is not able to do is not
functional rather far protein is
phosphorylated by fuse 3 as shown in my
lab and vivo by Matthias Peter and in
Gustav Omar's lab in vitro so far one is
phosphorylated in its phosphorylated
form far one is associated in a complex
with seal unto and CDC 28
and it's this complex so this is so far
then inhibits this activity either by
directly inhibiting the activity or by
causing ceylon to to become unstable at
any rate the important point is that far
associates with these only when it's
phosphorylated and thereby inhibits
their function now this is an overview
of the cell signaling pathway Jerry said
we should find common features in in
these different signaling systems and
and this is one way of thinking about it
and overview the mating factor response
pathway in the presence of alpha factor
you have an activated receptor and then
there are a whole herd of protein
kinases which act to phosphorylate in a
cascade but also there's some complex
epistasis relationships in yeast which
indicate that maybe there's some
phosphorylation of each other and
complicated ways at any rate they then
do a variety of things they have
multiple substrates they have a lot of
different targets and so the cell can do
a lot of things including activating a
transcription factor and of course a
transcription factor can have multiple
targets meanwhile back at the ranch the
protein kinases can be turning off can
be involved in desensitization
adaptation so you see that really with
just a simple molecular machinery
protein kinases and transcription
factors one can program a cell to do a
lot of different things now the last
part of the description of a budding
yeast I want to give some comments about
morphogenesis and how its programmed
genetically and how that can be
influenced environmentally the yeast
cell budding yeast makes a bud and this
bud the yeast cell has a lot of polarity
and that's reflected in the arrangement
of the cytosin cytoskeletal components
for example actin filaments are arranged
in this manner and they're acting dots
in the in the bud and near the neck all
cell surface growth is here and that's
presumably because this is orienting
vesicles to be
to be delivering their contents to the
daughter bud and then finally there
microtubules extra nuclear microtubules
emanating from the spindle pole body
which point towards the new bud how is
that polarity of a yeast cell
orchestrated or programmed well it turns
out that it's that it was immediate
interest to us because it's different
depending on the cell type so in a
cell's or alpha cells the first bud
comes out like this the next bud
typically comes out near the axis of
where it had divided previously in the a
alpha cell type in contrast the next
buds typically come out from the end so
sometimes one comes near the junction
that's the bipolar pattern so we'd like
to understand how the mating type locust
programs the different planes of cell
division here in this case it switched
to be in this direction here it
maintains in this direction this is a
picture of the axial pattern this is an
axial pattern exhibited by alpha alpha
diploid x'
their alpha cells and they bow give
axial pattern here a alpha cells and
they give this elongated pattern here
budding from the ends now the ability to
two bud in a characteristic manner
reflects some interesting
reorganizations that take place during
the cell cycle if we look at the end of
mitosis where the spindle pole bodies
are at opposite cell opposite poles here
we see that in an al in an a cellar an
alpha cell where the new bud is going to
come out here near the junction of the
previous ones it's known from work of
Breck fires that the spindle pole body
is oriented towards the bud let me just
say right now we don't think the spindle
pole body is saying where to make the
bud we think it's following instructions
from something that's at at the site of
the new bud at any rate we know that
this has the spindle pole body does have
to move and that process occurs in an a
cell or an alpha cell but notice in an a
alpha cell most of the time or much of
the time the spindle poles having gone
to opposite poles at the end of mitosis
can just sit there they do not have to
undergo
movement this movement here law
sometimes this one does move in the
mother cell so there's some kind of
regulation of movement of the of the
guts of a cell now john chant who's and
within a few months going to take a
position in Doug's department as a
graduate student in my lab began a very
prolific attack or productive attack on
this problem by looking for mutants that
are unable to exhibit this phenotype he
looked for mutants that did not give the
axial phenotype they were defective
somehow in this process and the mutants
turn out to have two different
phenotypes in some cases the mutants
exhibit a bipolar phenotype in other
cases they exhibit a random phenotype
now and thinking about and these are all
due to knockout mutations to loss of
function mutations so we arranged this
information into a more for genetic
hierarchy here and say that there one
this is one view I'll show you another
of you in the next slide there's a
random pattern and then it gets
converted to a bipolar pattern by the
action of bud one two and five that gets
converted to an axial pattern by bud
three and bud four
the the major point I want to make here
is that we can propose a hypothesis for
why a cells which give an axial pattern
differ from a alpha cells which give the
bipolar pattern and that resorts to our
knowledge that a alpha cells have a
repressor a 1 alpha 2 so we can propose
simply that a1 alpha 2 in addition to
turning off a Cho and T y1 and
transcription of many genes involved in
a mating pathway turns off bud 3 or bud
4 and you see bud 3 a bud for necessary
to give axial pattern so if a 1 alpha 2
represses bud 3 about 4 or somehow there
act activity then one gets a bipolar
response so this shows how the mating
type locus can control morphogenesis and
the plane of cell division in yeast and
I'll come back to that with used to log
all this is an update because as a if as
one as I have looked at this pattern for
a year or so and if you look at it too
much you start to believe that even
though there are other ways of thinking
about it and here's another way of
thinking about it another possibility is
that there's again a bipolar pattern and
an axial pattern in the bud 3 and bud 4
are necessary to convert this to this
but you could also say that either one
of these patterns can decay and that bud
1 2 and 5 lock these patterns into
position we really don't know exactly
the molecular machinery what bud 1 2 & 5
how bud 1 2 & 5 worked to program the
pattern but in the last few minutes of
this first part of the talk I want to
tell you give you an update on the
molecular machinery that bud 1 2 & 5
genes are defined but before I do that
let me say something about another group
of genes involved in budding pattern
this is a group of genes and this work
is really based from John Pringles lab a
group of genes typify by CDC 24 which
has the phenotype that at non-permissive
conditions instead of giving a bud
localized growth it undergoes uniform
cell surface growth so these genes CDC
24 42 43 and BM 1 are
necessary to restrict growth to a
certain point now CDC 24/40 cdc42 is a
member of the ROE family so it's a small
low molecular GTP binding protein CDC 43
is a subunit of a journal journal aiding
enzyme which is thought to which is Oh
certainly which is I think it's been
shown to parental late cdc42 I'll talk
about them one CDC 24 is a is a quantum
nucleotide exchange protein now the idea
then is that the bud proteins which are
important for telling the cell where to
make a bud
organize these proteins here which
define the budding site which restrict
budding to one position and the
hypothesis is that these proteins
organize the cytoskeleton actin and
tubulin and we don't have any direct
evidence on this any biochemical
evidence but we and John Pringles lab
that as Janet Chenevert and my lab and
Kathy Corrado and Pringles lab sequence
BEM won and showed that BEM one has two
sh three domains which are thought to be
involved in organizing actin although
they may not do it by directly binding
to actin so the idea then is that the
bud proteins bud 3 and bud floor
recognize a landmark at the old junction
between mother and daughter and then bud
3 and bud 4 somehow organize the other
proteins the CDs 24 etc to that site and
then they ultimately organize actin and
tubulin now we know something about bud
1 2 & 5 and I want to go into this
because there's now a new regulation at
the NIH that everybody has to work on
low molecular weight GTP binding protein
so you see the impact on the Brown &
Goldstein lab they no longer work on
cholesterol it's all rap and stuff like
that ok they're cringing in the first
row ok so it turns out that bud 1 is
similar to rest that was shown by Alan
bender and John Pringles lab it's a rasp
relative
and bud 5 John chance sequencing showed
that a similarity to CDC 25 in Sarah VCI
which is a guanine nucleotide exchange
protein so the idea then is that bud 1
has two states and those are
interconvert are those are switched by
bud 5 more recently a hey Oak Park a
postdoc in the lab sequence bud 2 which
was cloned by John chant it has
similarity to get proteins and hey Oak
has now shown that bud 2 has gap
activity against bud 1 in vitro so we to
do enzymology not just goldstein and
brown okay so so we have bud 1 has two
states a gdp-bound form at a gtp-bound
form and there's a bud 5 which is
proposed to catalyze nucleotide exchange
and bud 2 which looks like a gap what do
these proteins do this is this is a
hypothesis we really don't know how they
interface with the rest of the proteins
but the the scheme is as follows is that
is that bud 1 may be involved in
bringing important proteins to the
budding site for example perhaps the
gtp-bound form interacts with CDC 24 it
brings us to the mix brings it to the
budding site once at the budding site
but one which let me just comment has a
CT il at its carboxy terminus and so
it's likely to be journal generated so
bud 1 is brings us here and now at this
position the bud site may be bud 2 is
located here the gap protein causes
hydrolysis to GDP but one can exit
leaving behind CDC 24 get recharged etc
so the idea is that there's a cycle of
interchanging bud one in two modes which
may be involved in in assembling some
process or in locking in some morphic
genetic step at the budding site that's
the working hypothesis obviously we need
now to put up or shut up and find out
what bud 1 interacts with
let me just leave the morphogenesis
process and bring it back to the idea of
cell-cell interaction by noting that
yeast cells orient their cytoskeleton in
response to the mating partner we've
just seen that yeast cells growing
vegetatively have a programming of where
to bud they but axially they bud in a
bipolar manner depending on their
depending on whether they're what their
cell type is but the interesting thing
is is that when two cells a cells and
alpha cells come near each other they
reorient their cytoskeleton towards each
other so it appears that there's some
kind of morphic genetic signal that is
generated by cell-cell interaction so
that the yeast cell reorients its
cytoskeleton so now they they orient the
cytoskeleton towards each other so that
at the time of cell fusion there's an
appropriate nuclear fusion involving
subunits of the nuclear membrane in the
spindle pole apparatus now in summary
then there are I've talked about two
different morphological forms of yeast
the haploid gives axial budding the a
alpha cell it gives bipolar budding and
in Jerry Fink's lab Jimeno at all have
shown that when a alpha cells are
starved nutritionally they undergo
another form they have extreme
elongation an accentuation of elongation
and they don't undergo cell separation
so they make a pseudo Highfill form
which they argue and it's irrational
proposal is involved in foraging so
these are the three different
morphological forms of yeast and this is
an introduction then to the next part of
my talk which concerns used to lago made
us now used to lago made us well I will
show you that it has a lot of the same
machinery as in budding yeast it's got
homeodomain proteins and it's got
signaling systems and pheromones but it
deploys all this machinery in a slightly
different way and every time you you
think you understand used to lago and
you base your thinking on how yeast does
a certain way use the lago trips you
so don't make any assumptions this is a
this is organism from Mars really it's a
very interesting one it's a fungal
pathogen of corn it's a member of the
smut fungi which cause a variety of
disease in this case on corn the disease
is characterized by tumors on leaves
stems and cobs the hosts range is on
corn and teosinte but not on other close
relatives or relatively close relatives
like millet and it needs the plant to
complete its life cycle as I will show
you there are there's a developmental
switch in this organism there haploids
forms which are yeast like the
unicellular they grow on plates and
there non-pathogenic and they mate to
form a die carrion which is filamentous
this is the pathogenic form and it needs
a plant to complete its life cycle I'll
go into detail in a moment but there are
two life cycle that are needed to to
mating type low-side that are required
for the government's life cycle the a
locus has two alleles a1 and a2 the
belogus has 25 alleles B 1 through B 25
and in order to complete its life cycle
cells have to differ at both low side
and the work on youstill hago has
there's been a rejuvenation of
inflorescence on this organism by these
people salad liang and madison developed
transformation flora bond wet at ucsf
has been doing genetic analysis and
cloning the mating type low syas have
these other people and done other work i
will show you
regina common has been cloning the
mating type locus partially in
collaboration and has also cloned and
characterized the a locus so these are
the people that are responsible for a
lot of information about this organism
in the last five years all the photos I
will show are taken by flora bond wet
this is a haploid form of ustah Lago
it's a more elongated than Sarah VCI
and here's a bud and you see it has one
nucleus
after mating there's a filamentous form
produced and you see this filament has
two nuclei it's a dye carry on and here
is a whole bunch of more filaments and
this is an assay on upon Petri plates
where the dye carrier filament formation
is seen by formation of these so white
fluff here more filaments now this is a
very interesting photos which show a
haploid cell here you see it's haploid
nucleus and here you see some cells that
are mating here's one nucleus here's
another nucleus here's a here's a dye
carry on here and this shows an
intermediate in the mating process so
the cells mate with each other to form
the dye carry on now as I'll mention the
a locus in yeast in in yeast the mating
type locus codes for regulatory proteins
and the mating pheromone genes are
scattered throughout the genome and the
receptors are what Regina Commons lab
found is that the a mating type locus
actually codes for the mating pheromones
and the receptors and these mating
pheromones and receptors then presumably
facilitate the mating process and then
later you get to filamentous die carrion
so here's the life cycle you form a die
carry on the die carry on infects the
plant now it causes tumor formation in
the plant and Jeff Schell we'll be
talking about at what Agra bacteria does
to a plant among other things and in
this case used to Lago causes tumors in
corn but nobody knows the molecular
mechanism so it turns on tumor formation
and within the tumor the fungus
differentiates so this is one example of
cells so interaction it differentiates
within the plant to make T Lea spores
and these are diploid spores and then
when they germinate it undergoes meiosis
so this shows you some of the the actual
tumors this is on us on the leaf
on the midrib of the leaf this shows you
why corn geneticists are not fond of you
stole ago this is from Ginni Walberg
field and this is the ear of corn that
she was very happy to give flora and
this year these are more or less normal
ears I mean more or less normal kernels
and these here are individual kernels
that have been infected by you still ago
and then they're completely filled with
City spores and that's why they called
smut and when young ears of corn are
infected they're actually a delicacy but
obviously this is no delicacy this shows
tumors on on a leaf and you see that the
tumors have formed and there is also
induction of anthocyanins these are now
some thin sections and this beautiful
color here is the anthocyanin the purple
color this is the plant cell here and
this is now plant cells once again but
you see threads of the infecting fungus
and these are T Lea spores being formed
here these are later stages of Tullius
board development and the final stage of
T list for development so there are two
steps in the life cycle and let that
describe where they're cell-cell
interactions first of all the fungus
induces the plant to make a tumor and
then within the tumor the the the the
host induces the fungus to differentiate
to undergo nuclear fusion and to
differentiate into the chilliest borer
in no case of these signals known here
what we do know from the work of from
cloning by fro lugar and Liang and by
cloning and sequencing former genus
Commons lab that the a locus codes for a
mating factor and a receptor and a2
allele codes for another receptor and
another mating factor and as Mike Brown
mentioned yesterday the parental ation
was discovered on fungal mating factors
of a different Mississippi or my seat
tremolo mesenteric O is one of them a
truly obscure organism where very we're
not too much work is done on the biology
at any rate so this ustah Lago is also
of the city on my seat and lo and behold
it has mating factors which have all the
hallmarks of those farnesylated mating
factors they're short they have the kaxe
box on the end and it's not a leucine
okay the code for components of a
pheromone responds pathway presumably
important for cell fusion
now here's that's just like yeast except
that that the genes are at the mating
type locus now this is a surprise
this these pheromone and the response
system are important for maintenance of
the filament to state this is not
obvious so they're necessary for
maintenance of the filament the state so
the the dye carry on needs to signal
itself to maintain this state here and
the reason we know that is from flora
Vaughn what's observation that the a
locus is necessary for maintenance to
fill them at the state doubly
heterozygotes trains or filamentous
strains that are homozygous for a are
non filamentous so somehow the
pheromones are triggering the proper
morphological differentiation we know
that otto canned responses occur in a
lot of cancer cells and I don't know how
common it is in normal cells but it's
something that I'm staying tuned for
since it's cropped up here now the
signal transduction pathway in and in
this fungus we think it's going to be
similar to that and in budding yeast and
efficient yeast their receptors
identified from Commons lab and flora
has identified a gene fuzz 7 which is
related to the presume map kinase kinase
sterile 7 or B yr 1 and she cloned the
gene and this shows you the similarity
of fo7
to the other fungal protein kinases if
she knocks the gene out instead of
getting this fuzzy this mating response
she doesn't get the response so fuzz 7
is important for the response to the
mating factors in some way and
whether it's important for responding to
plant signals is not known now that's
the a locus the a locus codes for mating
pheromones and for pheromones the B
locus codes for regulatory proteins to
regulatory proteins that are both homeo
domain proteins the original locus was
cloned was cloned originally by commons
lab and by flora Bonwit and by Leon and
Kronstadt and then the common labs show
that there is another polypeptide coated
at that locus so they're two homeo
domain proteins called W and E they
these proteins have a constant region
that's similar low enough to go into
that in a rate they have a homeo domain
protein and the twenty five alleles any
combat this locus any combination of two
different alleles results results in
pathogenicity and this is a regulatory
protein deletion analysis mutational
analysis by common showed that that the
active species is a heterodimer of a one
w protein and one a protein for example
w of the W protein from the B one allele
and the e protein from the b2 allele so
that low and behold the active species
is a hetero marek or hetero dot or
hetero hetero oligomeric protein so
heteromeric regulatory proteins are a
molecular signature for diploid cell
type in budding yeast a1 alpha 2 and for
dikaryotic cell types in fungi so e 2 W
1 or e 1 W 2 and you made us and then an
other fungi for example the wood rotting
fungus guys at film commune also has
such a system so fungi and yeast is a
single celled fund fungus fungi had had
make use of these combinatorial
regulators composed of multiple
different types of subunits to program
their lifecycle now what are the targets
of regulation by the youstill hago
heteromeric protein will call it b1 b2
for some plus
so we know that cells that are that have
b1 b2 that are that are die carry-ons
have the following properties they
induce tumors their filamentous and
there's a prophetic which means they
cannot grow on plates in the lab so
these this regulatory protein here
somehow activates tumor formation and it
activates filament formation and it
inhibits sacrif it ik genes now let's
remember that this at least in Sara BCI
is a repressor so we should at least
keep an open mind and consider that
maybe this turns on these processes by
inhibiting an inhibitor so this may be a
repressor which activates tumor genes by
inhibiting Z and flora has identified
mutants that are candidates for being
defective in Z the inhibitor of tumor
formation likewise this might activate
filament formation by inhibiting an
inhibitor of filament formation this is
where I want to remind you about the
genetic control of morph of
morphogenesis and budding yeast where I
argued that a 1 alpha 2 may bud 3 and
bud 4 or otherwise inhibit their
activity that's exactly what I'm showing
here symbolically that the repressor
there may be a repressor which turns on
the appropriate filamentous mode of
growth by turning off something so flora
has identified other genes that are not
at the mating type locus that may be
regulated by these proteins and I'll
just call your attention to fuzz 1 and
fuzz 2 which are necessary for various
steps of the life cycle RTF which may be
a repressor of tumor formation the idea
now is to clone these genes and find out
what they do and see if they're
regulated so in conclusion what I've
tried to do in this tour of two
organisms is to show you how regulatory
proteins and cell signaling events
control the the specialized properties
of these cells including their
morphology and to show you that there's
some similarities in the machinery but
that they're put together in different
ways to allow these organisms
to do quite different things thank you
[Applause]
Thank You IRA for a very nice talk our
next speaker is bob horvitz who is here
and will talk about genetic control of
cell signaling and C elegans
you watch
okay as Doug said what I'm going to do
this morning is describe aspect to
aspects of the development of the
nematode C elegans two aspects
specifically that are regulated by cell
interactions first I'm going to discuss
a mesodermal cell migration that is
controlled by a long-range signal from
another tissue the gonad and then second
I'll discuss the development of the
vulva of the hermaphrodite which also
involves a single from the gonad the
first slide how it shows the organism
our studies of both vulval induction and
mesodermal migration derived from a
long-standing interest in the egg-laying
system of C elegans C elegans lays eggs
through its Volvo which is located right
here and if you look at the egg-laying
system you can see that it basically
consists of four components first of all
the uterus which stores eggs secondly
the vulva which is the opening through
which eggs are laid thirdly a set of
Volvo and uterine muscles when these
muscles contract the uterus is
contracted squeezing the eggs within and
the vulva uterine opening is forced open
forcing the eggs out these muscles are
innervated by a pair of neurons known as
the hsn's which drive egg-laying now a
few years ago Jim Thomas who was a
postdoc in the lab and is now on the
faculty at the University of Washington
in Seattle
Jim discovered a mutant in which the
egg-laying system can be displaced for
example here we see this mutant dig one
displace gonad the egg-laying system is
looking a little bit like a biplane
that's not too accurate here in the
wild-type animal we can see it located
near the mid body position and here's an
example of a displace gonad thats
displaced anteriorly up to this position
here
now what Jim discovered was that
interestingly dig one animals with
displaced don't ads of this sort can lay
eggs and it turns out the reason that
they can lay eggs is that all of those
other components are similarly displaced
and the reason that they're displaced is
that the development of these other
components is controlled by signals from
the gonad and so what I'm going to focus
on today is how the gonad controls
specifically the development of the
vulva again the opening and the vulva
and uterine muscles I'll start with the
muscles there are 16 vulva and uterine
muscles and they are derived from two
sex mile blast cells known as the SM
cells the Volvo and uterine muscles are
located 8 on each side of the animal and
each of these eight is derived from a
sex mile blast and SM Cell located on
each side the two sm's are generated
posterior Li actually both of them are
derived from a single post embryonic
mesodermal blast cell called M which
undergoes a number of rounds of division
so that we get one SM on each side of
the animal and the SMS then migrate and
you can see they migrate anteriorly
about a quarter of the length of the
animal until they reach a position
midway in the developing Gonet after
this point each SM divides three times
generating a total of eight descendants
four of which become vulval muscles four
of which become uterine muscles in dig
one animals the migrating sms migrate to
the position of the displaced gonad and
this can be true even when the gonad is
displaced not only anteriorly but also
dorsally and in this kind of situation
we see the SMS going all the way forward
and then up this observation suggested
that perhaps the gonad is attracting
these migrating cells
Jim Thomas and uh later with Michael
Stern a postdoc who's now on the faculty
at Yale Jim and Michael tested this
hypothesis using a laser micro beam to
ablate the gonad these animals are very
small they're also transparent so we can
see inside them we can see single cells
and if you can see a cell you can kill
it with a laser the laser basically
looks like that and we just shoot the
laser in through the EPI illuminator of
a microscope focusing it down to the
specimen on a slide and the resolution
of the laser is very small here for
example you may or may not be able to
see a single cell in the tail and the
size of the essentially
diffraction-limited beam that can be
used to kill inside the animal any cell
when this experiment was done for
example destroying the gonad in a dig
one animal what was found was that the
SMS now no longer migrated to where the
gonad was in other words the gonad is
attracting these cells however the cells
still migrate so it's not that the gonad
is causing the migration but rather that
the gonad in a sense is calling the
cells home telling them where to
terminate their movement now Michael
Stern was interested in this process and
for this reason he sought and
characterized a number of mutants that
were abnormal in the migration for
example he characterized mutants that
were defective in egg-laying and it
turns out not surprisingly that an
animal can be defective in egg-laying
for many different reasons he examined
egg-laying defective mutants and the
light microscope with polarized optics
which allows visualization of the
egg-laying musculature and he looked for
animals that were lacking these vulva
and uterine muscles in this way he
identified a series of genes with
different defects in steps of sex mile
blast development defects in the
original M lineage which generates the
SMS in the specification of the fate of
the SM cells which also includes a cell
that a gene that's been known for a long
time loon 12:3 genes that are involved
in SN migration mutants defective in any
of
these three genes eggl means egg laying
defective SEM means sex mail blast
defective and the name depends upon how
the mutants were isolated in the first
place
mutants defective in any of these three
genes show defects in sex mail blast
migration for example here we see the
characteristic defect in mutants in the
gene eggle 15 the wild-type animal
always shows the sex mile blast
migrating to the same quite fixed
position and an eggo 15 mutants the
migration is defective and these cells
terminate earlier now Michael ablated
the Gonet using the laser in eggl 15
mutants and what he discovered was that
in eggl 15 mutants without a gonad the
sex mile blast migrated further than an
eggo 15 mutants with them go Ned in fact
even further sometimes than in the
wild-type animal itself what this
observation indicated and this is very
important I think is that the
termination of sex mile blast migration
in Eagle 15 mutants is a consequence of
an interaction with the gonad in other
words the gonad is causing these cells
to stop migrating and if you remember
normally the gonad is calling these
cells so what seems to be happening is
that there's a reversal in the sign of
the interaction between the go Ned and
the migrating sex mile blasts okay a go
15 therefore looked like a gene that was
involved in controlling this migration
and the interaction involved in this
migration and Michael genetically
analyzed this gene for example he
obtained new mutations in the gene on
the basis of their failing to complement
existing mutations and he characterized
these new mutations by making animals
that were homozygous for them what he
found was many of the new mutations like
the original mutation caused a defect in
sex my Oblast migration but in fact many
of the mutations caused a much earlier
defect in development caused the animals
to fail to develop beyond the first
larval stage
and in fact his genetic experiments
indicated that a total loss of function
of egill 15 led to larval developmental
arrest indicating that this gene must be
functioning not only in sex my Oblast
migration but also in earlier aspects of
development in addition he isolated a
temperature-sensitive mutation the
mutation in 1477 this means it was the
14 hundred and seventy-seventh mutation
characterized in our lab and at 25
degrees and 1477 animals are extremely
sickly and they grow very poorly what
that meant was that Michael could grow
in 1477 animals at 15 degrees where they
were quite healthy generate large
numbers of individuals and basically
mutagen eyes these and look then at 25
degrees and not permissive temperature
for revert n't of this sick phenotype in
other words he was looking for
suppressors of egill 15 he obtained the
variety of these and the suppressors
defined a new gene that's involved in
sex myeloblast migration a gene known as
clear one clear because when you look at
the animal that's particularly clearly
visualized here we see the angle 15
mutant compared to the wild type and you
can see what I mean when I say this
animal is rather sickly by comparison an
eagle 15 clear one double is a much much
healthier animal this is the kind of
reverting that Michael obtained now what
was interesting was that when clear one
mutations are separated from eggo 15 the
clear one mutation alone results in a
very sickly animal what this means is
that Eagle 15 in clear one mutations are
mutually suppressive and this suggests
that these genes may be controlling and
tagging istic processes operationally
what this meant was that Michael could
use clear one mutants and seek
suppressors of these mutations we know
for example from this experiment the one
suppressor of these of this kind of
mutation is Eagle 15 so he could get
more Eagle 15 mutants by suppressing
one so he identified suppressors of
clear one indeed got more Eagle fifteen
mutants and also identified a variety of
other cells on the basis of this
experiment and through these kinds of
experiments he identified in fact a
total of seven interacting and
antagonistic genes that are involved in
sex mile blast migration one of these
genes gene called Sam five turned out to
clearly be involved in sex mile blast
migration because when this gene when
the mutation in this gene was separated
from clear one it led to a premature
termination of sex mile blasts migration
just as Eagle fifteen and the other
mutants that I referred to earlier so
he's got new mutants defective in sex
mile blast migration by getting
suppressors of suppressors and one of
the genes and the one I want to focus on
in this talk is the gene Sam five the
reason I want to focus on it is that it
turns out that SEM five is involved in
signal transduction not only in sex mile
blast migration but also in volvo
induction and so to tell you about its
role in volvo induction i'll turn now to
the process of vulval induction because
in fact vulval induction has been
studied much more extensively than sex
mile blast migration and we know a lot
more about both the genes and the
protein products that they encode that
are involved in this process let me
start with a description of vulval
development and particularly a model for
vulval development that i should say has
been in many regards developed by paul
Sternberg who was a graduate student in
our lab and is now on the faculty at
Caltech mobile development involves a
set of six cells shown here that are
located along the ventral side of the
animal below the developing Gonet these
cells divide they undergo a series of
divisions and Morpha genetic changes
until the vulva opening is formed as
seen here in the adult if we describe
these cell division patterns formally by
a cell lineage pattern we can see that
the six cells undergo basically three
distinct kinds of patterns of divisions
one cell generates eight descendants
this pattern is called the primary
pattern two of the cells generate seven
descendants each and are set to undergo
the secondary lineage these 22
descendants are the cells that form the
vulva itself these three cells are
called P 3 4 and 8 P because they're the
posterior daughters of cells known as P
3 4 and an 8 these three cells divide
once each in what's called the tertiary
lineage and these descendants are non
vulval descendants they don't form part
of the vulva now if we look at what is
currently believed to be the best model
for vogel development we see as shown in
this slide that there seemed to be three
sets of cell interactions that are
involved and basically I won't go
through the details the the basis of
this model has been published certainly
in in much detail but just outline the
idea the idea is that there are a set of
six equipo ten cells each of these cells
could express any of the three fates the
eight descendants seven descendant or
two descendant the primary secondary or
tertiary fates which fate each cell
expresses depends upon cell interactions
one of these interactions is an
inductive interaction a single cell in
the gonad known as the Anchor cell and I
should say this is a different cell from
the cells in the gonad that control the
sex mile blast migration a single cell
in the gonad appears to send a spatially
graded signal that can act at a distance
where that signal is strong the nearest
precursor cell expresses the primary
fate where the signal is weaker cells
expressed the secondary fate and where
the signal is weaker still or
non-existent cells express the tertiary
fate that's the inductive signal and
it's inductive signaling that's going to
form the basis of most of what I'm going
to talk about in the rest of the talk
this morning now the inductive signal
seems to act by overriding an inhibitory
signal an inhibitory signal from the
epithelial covering that envelops the
animal
and this epithelium the syncytial
hypodermic all of these cells from
expressing vulva lineages and what the
inductive signal does is overcome this
inhibition okay so I think that's
actually a very important thing to think
about because what it indicates is that
the cells that are induced by the Anker
cell to undergo vulval development do
indeed have that potential intrinsically
but are prevented from expressing it by
an inhibition from another tissue this
sounds very analogous to what we've
heard about from Doug Melton in his
remarks this morning where he is telling
us that neural induction which is
induced by the mesoderm may in fact be
inherently a potential of the cells that
normally become neural cells but that
the mesoderm might be inhibiting an
inhibition okay same kind of picture
here the Anker cell seems to induce
vulval development by inhibiting an
inhibition the third interaction that's
involved here is essentially a lateral
signaling amongst the six precursor
cells such that a cell that is
expressing the primary fate causes its
nearby neighboring cells to express the
secondary fate together these three cell
interactions result in the
characteristic pattern of cell fates 3 3
2 1 2 3 again I won't go through the
details but just give you a couple of
examples of the kinds of observations
that leads one to believe in this model
here for example is a dig one animal if
the gonad oh if the gonad and hence the
gonad Alankar cell is displaced we get a
displacement in the fates expressed by
these cells instead of going 3 3 2 1 2 3
they go 3 2 1 2 3 3 similarly if the
Anker cell is killed with the laser so
there now is no inducing cell all 6 of
these cells will express the non vulval
tertiary fate it is this experiment that
says the anchor cell induces vulval
development ok to analyze the molecular
genetic basis of vulval induction we
have for a number of years now been
isolating in care
terrorizing mutants defective in this
process initially chip Ferguson who's
now on the faculty at the University of
Chicago studied about 200 such mutants
and they basically defined two
phenotypic categories here's a wild-type
animal with a vulva
here is a vulva less animal if an animal
does not produce a vulva because C
elegans is internally self-fertilizing
it still produces progeny the progeny
hatch in utero and result in this
cuticle of the adult surrounding about
fifty little larvae this is a vulva less
mutant
by contrast below we see a multi vulva
mutant that generates a variety of vulva
like structures now in some of these
vulva lists and Volvo Multi vulva
mutants we see characteristic lineages
as shown here again the wild-type goes
three three two one two three and a
wild-type animal in which the inducing
cell has been killed goes all threes
hey volvulus mutant that is defective in
inductive signaling goes all threes just
like an animal that's missing the
inducing signal by contrast a multi
vulva mutant can show lineages as shown
here where all six of these cells
express either the primary or secondary
vulva lineages these mutants are
expressing vulva lineages even by cells
that normally do not do so mutants with
these kinds of cell lineage
characteristics are meetin's that we
believe to be abnormal and cell
signaling because we know that which of
these three fates each of these six
cells expresses is controlled by cell
signaling so we postulated in fact that
these were cell signaling mutants as and
as you'll see in a mutant in a minute
this hypothesis seems to be quite valid
to focus on the pathway of SIL
interactions Scott Clarke a graduate
student in the lab started with aim of
mutant that we believed to be defective
in cell interactions a mutant abnormal
in the gene Lyn 15 and isolated
suppressors of this mutant so for
example here's a linn 15 multi evolved
am of mutant
and he obtained 156 non move revert ins
of these when these mutants were
separated 80 of them led to evolve this
phenotype that indicated that these 80
mutations were perturbing vulval
development and therefore that the genes
involved were likely the genes defined
in this way were likely to be genes that
were in fact involved normally in vulval
development he characterized these 80 37
proved to be mutations in 19 suis knew
about 43 defined 9 new genes the nine
new genes are listed here and today I'm
gonna focus really on two of these genes
let sixty and SEM five some five I've
already mentioned from the sex mile
blast might in the sex of context of sex
mile blast migration let 60 which has
also been analyzed in Paul Sternberg's
lab at Caltech particularly by min Han
who was a postdoc there let 60 was found
by min Han to encode a rasp protein what
I'm going to tell you about first there
some genetic studies have let 60 and
then turned to some molecular studies
the genetic studies have been done both
by Scott Clark in our lab and also by
min Han in Paul Sternberg's lab and
basically what they found was that let
60 alleles are of four classes so these
are four different classes of mutations
in this wrasse protein first of all
there are mutations that activate the
protein they lead to a dominant multi
volva phenotype in other words they
cause an activation of the vulval
pathway there are mutations that
partially inactivate this gene and they
cause a recessive volvulus phenotype in
other words they block this pathway and
if the mutations are stronger they can
cause lethality there are also dominant
negative kinds of mutations that lead to
a dominus dominant volvulus recessive
lethal phenotype and there are mutations
that fully inactivate this gene that
lead to a recessive lethal phenotype
if we look at the lineages of these
mutants we see for example that both
classes dominant and recessive of the
volvulus mutants have the characteristic
of mutants that are defective in
inductive signaling okay so what this
says is that turning down this gene
leads to a block in the inductive
signaling pathway by contrast the multi
vova mutants in let sixty the ones that
by genetics activate this gene cause all
six of these cells to express volvo
lineages and they do so even if the go
natal Anker cell has been killed in
other words even if there is no signal
even if the whole gonad has been killed
okay so these wrasse activation mutants
lead to a constitutive activation of the
volvo pathway together these two
observations turning down the gene
blocks the pathway activating the gene
constitutively activates the pathway
these observations indicate that let 60
acts as a genetic switch and vulval
induction when on leading to an active
inductive pathway when off causing a
block in the vulval pathway and leading
to these alternative cell fates these
observations obviously are nicely
complementary to biochemical studies of
rass proteins that indicate that these
proteins function as biochemical
switches now Gregg by tell a graduate
student in the lab was interested in
learning the molecular nature of the
various classes of let sixty alleles I
already said that the let sixty protein
as found by min Han encodes a raster
protein you can see here that it's
really very strikingly similar to human
rest this is a comparison for example to
human unrest and here at the c-terminus
a comparison to human k wrasse
Gregg analyzed the sequences of our
various lists sixty mutations and for
example he found that the let sixty
multi vulva mutations which activate
this wrasse protein are all identical
jito a transition mutations causing
therefore identical substitutions of
glutamic acid for glycine at codon
thirteen
okay now codon 13 is I'm sure many
people know is one of a few codons that
activates Rast genes in both yeast and
mammals so the fact that mutations in
this activated C elegans wrasse gene
that activate the pathway the signal
transduction pathway for vulval
induction is similar to the oncogenic
mutations mammalian whereas i think is
quite interesting now if we look at the
recessive grass mutations the ones that
inhibit grass function partially or
completely if we look at the ones that
block the vocal induction pathway what's
interesting about them is that although
they indicate sites that are needed for
wrasse function these very same sites
have been studied and other wrasse
proteins initially by Doug Louise lab at
NCI and more recently by Chris Marshalls
lab in London these people have studied
the wrasse protein and asked whether or
not these sites are needed for the
function of a mutation li activated rest
in other words once activated by
mutation do these sites disrupt function
okay the answer and the most striking
answer i think comes from Chris Marshall
studies the answer is that for at least
codon 66 that that site is not needed
for a mutation li activated wrasse even
though for the same wrasse protein
namely Harvey wrasse that site is needed
for the normal RESP wrote in to work
this suggestion from these observations
is that at least codon 66 and maybe some
others of these mutations as well are
needed for the functioning of this
protein but not for its functioning once
it's been active
in other words the suggestion is that
maybe codon 66 and perhaps some of these
other sites that find places where
rasped proteins interact with their
activators and if they're activated
these sites are no longer important the
next slide shows mutations that result
in recessive lethality and I should say
that this recessive lethality that's
seen by loss of function of this Rass
protein is the same as the recessive
lethality that's seen by loss of
function of the SEM 5 protein namely
these animals fail to develop beyond the
end of the first or early second larval
stages and they assume a very
characteristic rigid rod like appearance
and I'll return to that a little bit
later
these recessive lethal mutations the
most interesting of them I think is the
one that affects codon 37 which is in
the so called effector domain of rass
and this is a region that's needed for
the activity of rass whether or not that
rest is mutation alee activated okay let
me turn at this point to the SEM 5 gene
which i've already said was identified
independently by Michael Stern studying
sex myeloblast migration and Scott Clark
studying the signal transduction
involved in vulval development together
they identified six different alleles of
this gene three of them were identified
by Scott on the basis of vulval
development and those three all also
have striking effects on cell migration
the other three alleles were identified
by Michael Stern as perturbing sex
myoblast migration and these three
appeared generally to be weaker alleles
and they do not seem to have very major
effects and a vulval development again
these mutations the loss of function
mutations in SEM 5 result in this
characteristic rod like larval lethality
indicating that it like led sixty
functions not only
these late signal transduction pathways
but also in an earlier developmental
process if we look at the vulval
phenotype of mutations perturbed in SEM
5 we see again this characteristic non
induced phenotype indicating that
mutations in SEM 5 block vole vole
induction Scott Clark and Michael stern
cloned and sequenced the gene and what
they found was that it encodes a protein
that consists almost entirely of sarcoma
Logie regions these are in the order SH
3 SH - SH 3 sarcoma low G regions are
non catalytic domains that have been
found in a variety of signal
transduction proteins that are regulated
by protein tyrosine kinases sh2 domains
bind directly to phosphotyrosine
containing proteins to the
phosphotyrosine residues in fact and as
our herskowitz has alluded to sh three
domains can interact in some way with
the cytoskeleton and also probably with
other proteins as I'll show in a moment
this C elegans m5 gene is strikingly
similar to a human gene known as grab to
grab - binds phospho tyrosine residues
in the human EGF receptor and it was
identified by Yosi Schlesinger's lab
Schlessinger and Michael Stern have
collaborated recently and shown that
human grab - can rescue C elegans m5
mutants indicating that these genes are
not only structurally but also
functionally similar now Scott Clark
sequenced the six alleles of saime v two
of them it turns out alter conserved G's
out within splice sites and presumably
cause aberrant splicing two of the
others effect
the two different amino terminal and
carboxy terminal Sh three domains and
they affect conserved residues within
these domains actually you can see on
this slide also the similarity between
grab two and SEM 5 in both the amino and
the carboxy terminal sh 3 domains a
mutation in either of these sh 3 domains
can decrease SEM 5 function what this
indicates is that both of these sh 3
domains are needed for function in other
words even though there are similarities
between them they are not functionally
redundant and in fact this concept is is
is confirmed in some sense by really
looking in detail at the 2 sh 3 domains
one can see that although they're both
clearly SH 3 domains they in fact are
not all that highly similar to each
other again indicating that they
probably function distinctly the final
two mutations that Scott identified
affect adjacent residues within the sh2
domain and again you can see here how
similar the grab to sequence is to the
SEM 5 sequence and what this indicates
is that these conserved residues are
presumably important for the function of
SH 2 which is involved in
phosphotyrosine binding ok based upon
its structure we can say then that SEM 5
seems likely to act as an intermediate
in the vulval signal transduction
pathway presumably by interacting with
at least one phosphotyrosine containing
protein so the question then is what
proteins are there that SEM 5 might
interact with to answer this question I
want to now turn to how both SEM 5 and
the let 60 wrasse gene all fit into the
overall pathway for vulval induction to
define a genetic pathway for vulval
induction we have constructed double
mutants between the various volvulus and
Multi vulva mutants here are the
volvulus here are some volt Multi vulva
mutants now if you think about it each
multi volva mutant is activating this
single transduction pathway each
volvulus mutant is in activating the
pathway so if a volvulus mutation is
acting downstream of a multi evolving
mutation that's activating the pathway
the volvulus mutation should prevent the
action of the activated pathway or the
activated multi völva mutation okay in
this way all of the doubles have been
constructed and what you can see here
for example is that the different multi
völva mutations seem to define different
sites with respect to this pathway in
comparison to the volvulus mutations for
example it appears that most of these
volumes are acting downstream of lynn 15
and upstream of lynn watt together these
kinds of experiments have indicated a
formal genetic pathway an order of gene
action within the vulval signal
transduction pathway which is shown here
combining this formal genetic pathway
what with what is known from studies of
both the structure and function of these
genes we believe that a plausible
molecular model for the single
transduction pathway is as shown on this
slide we start out here with the signal
which we believe is encoded by the gene
Lyn 3 Paul Sternberg's lab has found
that Lyn 3 encodes a protein that is
similar to mammalian growth factors EGF
and TGF alpha that the lynn 3 gene is
expressed in the anchor cell the cell
then induces global development and for
this reason it seems likely that lynn 3
encodes a growth factor like inducing
signal this signal presumably acts on
the let 23 receptor tyrosine kinase this
gene has been characterized molecular
lis in a collaboration between paul
Sternberg's lab and that of Oshima in
japan this receptor tyrosine kinase is
of the EGF receptor family and therefore
seems likely to be the receptor for the
growth factor like molecule SEM five
based on the genetic studies acts
between Lin 15 which causes a mud
phenotype and Lin one I'm sorry in let
sixty gain-of-function mutations in
which caused a mud phenotype and given
its structure we think it's very likely
that SEM five is acting by binding to
phosphotyrosine on this receptor
tyrosine kinase SEM five may well act
via a second gene that's in this part of
the pathway a gene called let 3:41 let
3:41 x upstream of the let sixty rass
gene which again is involved as a
genetic switch in this pathway let 60
rest interacts with and from some of our
studies and also those from Paul's lab
may well act upstream of but we're not
totally sure of this yet a gene called
Lin 45 which Paul's lab is very recently
shown encodes a rath protein our lab is
currently working on both Lin one and
let 3:41 to molecular Li clone these
genes and both our lab and Paul
Sternberg's lab has cloned Lin 15 Lin 15
turns out to be a complex genetic locus
that encodes two genetically distinct
distinct functions that encode two
genetically to molecularly distinct
proteins and these proteins both seem to
be novel in sequence now in addition to
the genes shown on this slide our lab
has been identifying and characterizing
additional genes in this pathway for
example carry Cornfeld a postdoc in the
lab and greg by tell have systematically
been seeking genes that act downstream
of let sixty as i discussed before
such genes can be identified because
genes that block the action of a
activated rass protein will prevent the
expression of the multi völva phenotype
caused by such a activated Rass protein
so what they've been doing is looking
for suppressors of the multi Volvo
phenotype caused by activated rests
so far they've identified 43 such
suppressor mutations these mutations
define 22 genes one of these genes is
Lin 45 and in fact it's on the basis of
the identification of this gene in this
way that we think that it's likely to be
acting downstream of rass if we look at
what they've done so far in
characterizing these genes three of them
are besides Lin 45 3 new genes stand out
as quite intriguing one of them has this
characteristic rod-like level lethal
phenotype which is seen for basically
all of the genes in the Volvo a single
transduction pathway and so we think
it's very likely involved in this and
also the earlier larval step that these
other genes function in two of these
genes lead to a vulval defect per se so
again we think it's very likely these
genes are involved in vulval development
so together we think that these
experiments have now identified three
new genes that act downstream of rass in
this signal transduction pathway
similarly Jeff Thomas a graduate student
in the lab has been genetically
analyzing the beginning of this
inductive pathway Jeff studies combined
with earlier work by chip Ferguson in
the lab have now identified a set of 13
genes that act to negatively regulate
the entire vulval transduction a signal
transduction pathway in a formal sense
these genes behave like tumor suppressor
genes and what I mean by that is that
loss of function of these genes lead to
the same phenotype the multi völva
phenotype that one gets with a gain of
function for example in the virus grass
activation leads to multi völva
inactivation of these genes leads to
multi Volvo okay the same phenotype is
rass activation
now what's interesting is the multi
vulva phenotype caused by these genes
requires mutations in two of these genes
to be expressed specifically what we see
is that these genes can be divided into
two classes that we call a a and B a
mutation in any one of these genes does
not perturbed oval development if we
have a double mutation in two Class A
genes or a double mutation in two Class
B jeans again vulval development as
normal but if there's a mutation in one
class aging any of these and one Class B
gene any of these then there is a multi
volva phenotype okay because of this
synthetic effect we call these genes
synthetic multi völva genes and I can
say just a very quick word about how
these genes have been isolated the first
of these was isolated as a multi vulva
mutant that when analyzed proved to show
a two gene effect in other words the
phenotype map to two locations and it
could be separated into two separate low
sigh each mutation alone gave a non MPH
unit phenotype but once we had strains
that carried either of these mutations
we could meet ojen eyes these strains
and look for new multi vulva mutants
some of the new mutants were single gene
Multi vulva mutants of the kind that I
described previously but some of them
were new synthetic multi vulva mutants
and once one had new synthetic multi
evolving mutants these could be
separated again non multi vulva mutagen
eyes new multi vulva okay and so one can
keep going generating more and more
genes always so far at least finding
genes to be in one of these two classes
in this way we've now identified a total
of 13 sin mob genes foreign Class A nine
and Class B we interpret the observation
that these observations by postulating
that there are two functionally
redundant classes of synthetic multi
Volvo genes
that act in parallel both act to inhibit
the vulval inductive pathway if one of
these two pathways is knocked out by
mutation the other is still sufficient
to inhibit this pathway one has to knock
out both of these pathways to cause a
constitutive activation of the vulval
inductive pathway and the expression of
that intrinsically intrinsic potential
that these cells have to generate the
volvo lineages so far we have cloned
four of these thirteen genes and based
upon the sequence analysis to date all
four encode novel proteins so exactly
how these genes act and how they
interact and negatively regulate this
signal transduction pathway is a major
goal of the work in the lab I'd like to
conclude at this point by reminding you
that the SEM five gene functions in
signal transduction both involve
induction and insects myoblast migration
in addition we have some evidence that
the clear one gene is also involved in
both of these pathways of the other
genes that we've characterized in both
pathways they seem to be separate in
other words they affect one pathway but
not the other and we can sort of diagram
this as shown here so what that means is
that sex myeloblast migration apparently
uses a different signal not the Lin
three growth factor and a different
receptor not the let 23 tyrosine kinase
and probably a different effector
molecule not to let 60 Rass gene however
given the sh2 domain of SEM 5 we assume
that there is a tyrosine kinase involved
and one of the major questions for
future work then is to identify all of
the other genes that are involved in
each of these two signal transduction
pathways what we hope then is to define
complete pathways for both of these and
in addition to reveal in this way the
degree to which these and other signal
transduction pathways and C elegans use
both specific and
Jean functions and I thank you
[Applause]